this Workshop it's been a great pleasure
to meet friends and also listen to very
exciting talks so ideally I would have
wanted to talk about the work we have
been doing on sampling from large
language models but so I wasn't able to
do that so I'm gonna give a title
that seems read almost like the title of
the workshop so it's too General so I
decided to narrow it down
this is upsetting me
so I'm I'm going to talk about some of
the works that I've been thinking about
over the past few years around fairness
and so just I think a lot of people have
talked about these problems so I'm just
going to give this example where so this
is done now the classic example where
you have a classifier and then you you
basically try to look at how does
classifier works for different subgroups
here white and African Americans and
then you see all of a sudden that the
the false positive rates of the
classifier is hugely different
for these subgroups and so that's
something that's very undesirable in
practice and so that's something that we
really want to be able to address
and we want to be able to address these
in again classic classification problems
that get deployed in practice and so
there are a lot of practical challenges
around actually getting any solution
into into these kinds of classifiers
so this was an extreme example but these
kinds of issues appear everywhere so
you're solving a PCA problem and then
you'll start looking at the performance
of your PCA for male and female then
then you see that there is a problem
you solve a Federated learning problem
and then you start looking at test
accuracy across your devices and then
all of a sudden you may be able to see
that there are some of the devices that
get extremely low accuracy
you look at
[Music]
other types of resources there is
clustering problem there is a metal
learning problems and then you solve The
Meta learning problem on average it
seems to be working well but then you
start looking at the worst performing
task and then you see there is a huge
discrepancy and so we are interested in
basically addressing these kinds of
issues in in practical
many Notions of
ten there is kind of no
one-size-fits-all answer so there is
individual fairness where basically very
similar to to privacy Notions so you
would desire similar outcomes for uh
similar individuals
uh or there are group fairness Notions
where so we as we're talking about uh
whites and African Americans so you have
subgroups and then you would want to
have a similar aggregate performance in
this case maybe loss maybe accuracy
maybe false positive rates uh of of your
classifier to be similar for different
subgroups and that's basically what the
focus of this work is
so there are
many different ways of doing algorithmic
furnace promoting approaches so I'm
citing two papers from Flavio
from 2017 and uh and uh the the recent
work that he talked about so there is
pre-processing there is in processing
and post-processing
and so
I'm going to argue for in processing
uh for two reasons one is that in
practice when we have these classifiers
so what happens is that there is the
data keeps changing
so you have this classifier that's going
to be trained maybe every week but every
week it's going to be trained on on a
new data and so you basically capture
the data and then you want to to
basically run the classification and
everything has to basically run
uh
uh in an automated manner
so the lesser the moving Parts the
easier so when you have an in-processing
model basically you just capture the
data you you run the training you get
the model and deploy it whereas now if
you have two different things that need
to run it just creates more
opportunities for things to go wrong
and from an information theoretic point
of view I'm going to argue that the in
processing is is probably going to to
dominate the other two so there is
opportunities for lots of information
for both pre-processing and
post-processing method
so I'm going to focus on on in
processing methods in in this work
okay so that brings us to the first uh
paper that I'm going to talk about so
it's uh relatively older uh in machine
learning years uh tilted empirical risk
minimization from iclr 2021 so the work
was led by Tian Lee who is a PhD student
at CMU is about graduate and in
collaboration with modular San Jovi and
Virginia Smith
and extended version of this paper is
actually going to appear in jmlr this
year
so what is empirical risk minimization
so in empirical risk minimization the
goal is to we have an empirical loss so
that could be cross entropy loss it
could be an L2 loss and then we average
out that loss over our samples and then
try to minimize that so here we're
solving a linear regression problem
which is basically a
an empirical minimization problem we
then have two laws or minus Square loss
and that's the the fit that we're
getting
so is that a good fit
so a lot of people may argue that no
this is not a great fit because so we
seem to see as kind of a structure
underlying pattern for this data that
we're not on kind of capturing here
and
what uh
this paper is all about is basically
just captured in one slide here so we
replace the the empirical loss with what
we call the tiltedem purple loss so what
we're doing is that we are exponentially
tilting the the individual losses and
then we are taking the empirical average
and we are properly scaling it back to
to uh have basically some nice
properties of of whatever loss function
that we had and then what happens here
is that if we have a positive T we're
going to end up highlighting these
outliers that we had here and if we have
a negative T this is going to start
suppressing the effect of those outliers
and so we're going to in effect get some
fairness
properties for positivities and some
robustness properties for negatives
now
this is so if you look at this basically
this is so if we look at the the loss
function loss or loss functions are
usually at negative log likelihood and
then so what we're doing here is in
effect we are looking at the scale
cumulent generating function of
information which is the
the negative blood calcium function now
there are many other ways of uh dealing
with these losses so I think there is a
great work by uh Mario Peter and Lalita
about Alpha losses that try to kind of
again have some tunable way of
calibrating classification in in here we
are so this is an information Theory
Workshop so we are going to look at some
something that is information
theoretically motivated so I'm uh for
the rest of this part of the talk I'm
going to try to talk about some of the
properties of this uh this objective and
then we will see some empirical results
yes
foreign okay so what are some of these
properties of the term objective so it
basically uh so it traverses between
mean loss to average loss to Max loss as
we send T from negative Infinity all the
way to positive Infinity
uh so and then it's kind of in a varies
between them in a smooth manner now if
you have a smooth loss function so you
will end up with a smooth objective
still
if you have your loss functions are
convex here so we have like so I'm
giving an example with three loss
functions that are quadratic so you will
end up with a convex objective for
positive key but you as you can see that
the objective becomes non-convex for
negative t
and so here are kind of the solutions
the minimizers of uh this uh these
objectives or that minimizers are not
unique so under some assumptions we can
assume that you will end up in a
parametric curve that you will be able
to Traverse the the solutions
and so here so it's a one-dimensional
example here is our median loss so it is
the median of these three functions
which is as you can see it's both
non-convex and it's uh
non-smooth and if you wanted to minimize
that it's it's a very hard problem to
solve in in general and so here so all
of a sudden one of the the solutions of
this term objective is is capturing that
but that's more generally even in higher
dimensional uh problems uh the term
could be related to these quantar
lessons and we will come back to that
so
this objective is basically
could also be Rewritten as a rainy cross
entropy
between the uniform distribution and
this W distribution so what is this W
distribution is basically it's uh
um our
the
Tilted loss for each individual kind of
data point which are normalized
okay and it could be also
let's talk about this W function a
little bit more so this W function is uh
what we call empirical mismatched tilted
postulated distribution so basically
that that the so if we remember that's
just the negative block likelihood so
this is just so for t e for T is equal
to one that's kind of the the gets back
the postulated distribution
and in essence what this is trying to
estimate is this quantity here where now
I'm looking at the postulated
distribution but I'm multiplying it by P
of X which is the the distribution that
was that the data was generated from and
then I'm I'm normalizing it uh
appropriately and we had come across
these kinds of tilted distributions in
earlier work in the context of uh
looking at mismatched guesswork so the
the guessing problem where now you are
trying to to do guesswork but then the
the distribution uh basically you're
ordering your
uh your sequences from most likely to
least likely according to a mismatched
distribution and then you won't want to
to understand the moments of guesswork
and these quantities actually appear in
in those problems as well uh I think
Lolita and Oliver has have like a great
paper on on that Source coding problem
as well
okay
these are connections to
to regularization of the empirical risk
and it actually saw it
later we realized that it's actually a
distributionally robust optimization
problem with a KL ball that is basically
as well
so it's basically related to a lot of
the the literature around uh machine
learning
so this is
H is
the best person
so it's written in a little bit of a
weird manner it does so okay okay yeah
Okay so
now how do you solve for this object
so this is the this is the objective
that we have and then uh we want to take
the its gradient and then if we take the
gradient we will see that it's basically
just the the weighted sum of the
individual gradients and the weights are
actually given bit by the W function
that we just uh saw so it's basically if
if you have a batch problem so you would
just compute these and then you take the
gradient but usually that's not the case
and we end up needing to solve these
things in using mini batches because
that's how optimization works at scale
oops
I don't know why this thing appeared
later but
uh so there is a stochastic solver for
this problem
uh so the stochastic solver the the way
it works is that every time you take a
mini batch uh of the data and then you
compute the Tilted loss and now the the
this tilted loss that you compute is uh
is going is basically we will need to be
able to keep track of so this RT is the
objective so we need to actually try to
keep track of the objective because
that's kind that's our normalizing
Factor
and in order to keep track of the
objective the The Proposal here is to
actually do a tilted average
of the previous steps
basically this is just the Dynamics that
that keeps track of the the previous
step and what our current estimate is
and then we normalize the weights
accordingly and then so that that we use
that to to update the parameters over
this this mini batch
and it turns out that we can get
convergence guarantees for this
algorithm so the convergence guarantees
have a really bad scaling with T so
there if I have is exponential scaling
which is but but that's not what we see
in practice but I think it it's a it's
an artifact of the analysis
okay
so I'm going to
talk about some of the applications of
um
of basically this tilted empirical risk
minimization yeah we applied it to a
variety of problems involving fairness
also robustness for for negative T's
where I'm going to come back to that and
then you could actually mix and match
fairness and robustness in in different
senses as well
so the first problem is a fair Federated
learning problem
as as you can see so the Federated
averaging
algorithm uh left a lot of some of these
devices
with accuracies that were extremely
small and then you could actually
apply the the term algorithm and then
with almost no loss on the on the
average performance you
uh you get a a lot smaller standard
deviation across these devices and then
divorce case performance so all of a
sudden it's improves dramatic
uh you could apply it to to the PCA
problem as well so it is basically so it
works that specifically try to address
PCA and so here we are just taking the
the PCA loss and then we're just trying
to to make them uh equal across the two
groups using the the term objective
you could use it for handling
representation bias or class imbalance
against again these are methods that
specifically designed for class
imbalance so we just applied it out of
the box here yes
particular sweep do you need to sorry is
a hybrid parameter yes how big of a
suite or like how do you know what range
to look like so that's a good question
so for
all of these applications with swept
basically between 0.1 and 10. and in
basically just five values and we need
uh so we used so in some cases you may
have a
validation sets that may have may be on
biased Etc so in the and that's
basically what we'll do
so we're optimizing TV on the
validations
but like in some of your plots too it's
going it looks like to use like 100
years
so yeah so in this one we just so if we
send T to Infinity you virtually get
Minimax uh object feeds back and so the
here the
uh the Baseline method was a Minimax
method we just wanted to show that you
could virtually get the Minimax methods
a performance back with a large enough T
but it's actually much much faster to
run this algorithm compared to the the
min max optimizer
so here is another one example that I
think is is actually very very
interesting so this is a metal learning
problem so you have a multitude of tests
and this is the objective that we wanted
to solve and then so basically it's a
model like not stick metal learning
method that solves the problem
uh gets a mean
um mean Square there
of 1.23 on all the tasks and then you
see that some of like the worst case
tasks get a really really bad
performance and so worth 10 like five
and there is a big standard deviation by
applying term what happens is that even
the mean improves so the not only the
worst case performance improves but also
we we get an improvement on the average
performance so that's impossible if
you're only thinking about the the kind
of the performance on the training data
so this just shows that we get kind of
we get models that generalize better
because this is we are what we are
looking at here is the tests
tests
means whether
okay so there is follow-up work on
semantic segmentation I think I can skip
this and so
come back to this question of now can we
use this objective to bound value at
risk so we know that we basically here
so this looks like turn off mounts and
we know how to use Channel fonts to to
uh to bound the the tail distributions
and so the question is can we actually
develop something similar here
what is value at risk so
solving at the losses that are larger
than some gamma and then we want to uh
we want to find the minimum gamma for
which the
the
that the quantile is smaller than Alpha
that's what we're going to call the var1
minus Alpha
and so
this is desirable in many applications
sometimes we want to for example
optimize for 90th percentile but these
quantile losses are very non-linear very
non-smooth and
um
non-smooth and non-convex so it's not
possible to optimize them so in practice
people have looked at what's called con
conditional value at risk that's kind of
a smooth up uh smooth upper bound on
value address and then you can actually
do CVA or optimization
and you know so it's it's it's used in
in in in in in a variety of contexts and
the question that we had is that can you
actually come up with a an upper bound
on VAR using term
uh to do that uh we first
derive a
an improved turn off Bound for
non-negative random variables uh and so
basically here is the statement of the
the result
so and so this is the vanilla turn off
Mountain so what we have here is just
the minus one when you have a
non-negative random variable so in
essence sometimes I've had this issue
myself where like you have you're
dealing with non-negative random
variables and you want to get
concentration bounds around zero
churn-off bounds are very loose and uh
but you you will end up actually
applying um the markup inequality and
that gives you like the desired results
and this recovers Markov inequality for
t equal to zero
and basically generalizes that another
difference is that now you're doing the
search over all keys negative as well as
positive and so sometimes actually the
negative T's are are going to be the
optimal t's for uh for this for this
pound
now the proof is super simple it's just
basically applying Markov inequality to
to this quantity for so now depending on
the whether T is positive or negative so
this is going to be here positive or
negative so you apply it twice and get
the better of the two months
and yeah just wanted to to show the this
uh
turn off Bound for two extremely simple
examples here uh the first one is
uniform02 distribution the second one is
is
a truncated normal distribution
and so this the red hair is the turn off
bound the the green curve is the true
complementary CDF and now the the the
the other curve that we have here is
actually so the improved turnoff bound
and so tion did a great job as at
visualizing the optimal value of T that
gives you this this bound and you see
that for these values is the optimal
value of G is actually negative
so we use this to derive an upper bound
on value at risk and so this is the
upper bound and the value at risk that
that we we got through this method
so and uh so it looks a little
complicated but it's the derivation is
is pretty simple using this new improved
channel of Mount uh what is important
here is that
uh when you get this so there is this
minimization over T but then in the end
of the day when we want to optimize this
upper bound now we want to do the
another minimization over Theta and
minimization over Theta is going to be
so everything is is kind of a constant
here and so doing the minimization over
Theta is as if you're solving the Tilted
risk minimization problem so the same
solver could be used to to kind of
derive these bounds and then
be vendor given the teller now you can
actually uh do the minimization over t
[Music]
each time
all right I think
um
35 is when you finish so two minutes two
minutes okay
yeah
okay
so let me skip this so I think I'm going
to
skip the negative two examples
Maybe
just talk about
one simple robust regression example
here the the problem that we are trying
to solve is a regression problem but now
we are either adding
noisy labels or noisy features
and the fun part is that you can apply
term with so if you're with a negative C
here we have in all of the regression
problem robustness problems we just you
chose T is equal to negative two
which worked you may be saying that
that's cheating so it probably is and so
we don't have a better way of kind of
optimizing T but it as you can see it's
like compared to
to
methods specifically designed for
regression it actually works uh much
better especially in high noise regimes
yes
and uh
I missed it yeah so I think basically so
if you look at it right there is nothing
that says that it has to be a
classification problem so what we are
doing is we are just taking whatever
loss function that you had and we're
tilting it and then
so you are using squid loss therefore
there we are using a square glass in the
Better Learning problem we were using
the natural learning plots in the PCA
problem that was a different loss so
it's basically any loss we could tell
you
so yeah with that I'm going to stop and
I think I should have change the title
to one so
[Music]
[Applause]
I also managed to ask questions
but I'm confusing simple but if you look
at the
the negative teeth
if you're multiplying the path by this
negative number doesn't that make bad
things better
so the one over so there is a one over T
that takes care of that oh look at that
that's negative
okay the one slide that skipped it shows
about C more
I wanted to know what that is
here
so so stevar is known to be an upper
bound and value at risk so this is not
our work
but now we are deriving a different
upper bound on value at risk through
these tilted losses so this image now
the so Steve are the optimization
problem is different right from the the
normal empirical risk minimization here
the the takeaway is that the
optimization over feta is exactly the
distance
now you have to do another optimization
on T which isn't really derive a kind of
a good way of round robbing the updates
on Theta and C so that's kind of left
open but at least the the optimization
over Theta is basically solving for
this objective
which is basically the term
is used by some folks as a famous
measure is that correct yes and I still
cannot wrap my head around it for some
reason but like do you have results in
the fairness context with t-bar so so
basically we so T Bar is nothing so in
the end of the day you solve this
problem right and then you it's as if
you're solving
preparation for a particular teeth and
so that's that those are the kind of
results that we showed so in a sense in
it it this just motivates the fact that
you're as if you're optimizing for the
90th percentile rather than the average
okay
thank you
[Applause]
you know you